bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors 70 % de oui
oui qui l'emportent très largement oui
en fait c'était à ses débuts et la libye
c'est peut-être même plus marquée que
prévu et ça montre effectivement que ce
mouvement de fond qui avait connu la
société chilienne depuis octobre 2019
lorsqu'il ya eu des temps on s'en
souvient des protestations très
important à la suite d'une hausse du
prix du transport du métro mais qui a
pris de l'ampleur justement du fait de
cette ce malaise qui avait dans cette
société
par rapport à vos inégalités partout
c'est l'idée des caractéristiques que
l'on avait assez souvent négligée est
effectivement tout ça donne aujourd'hui
ces mouvements assez assez consistants
ses massifs de recherche des recherches
d'une réforme justement et de la
constitution qui en quelque sorte celle
à la phase finale de cette transition
vers la démocratie qui a commencé au
début des années 90 et avec des lectures
des deux plus précisant elle wind et la
fin de la dictature de pinochet
alors justement qu'est ce qu'on
reprochait de cette constitution héritée
de pinochet
bon la constitution
effectivement les gens qui propose des
réformes les mouvements qui cas qui sous
tendent cette massive et démonstration
n'est pas de recherche un changement est
signalé en effet que et il fallait un
nouveau cadre institutionnel notamment
pour peut-être renforcer les droits
économiques sociaux et des citoyens pour
donner des modalités ou pour favoriser
des modalités de plus importante
participation citoyenne par exemple est
certes disons depuis quelques années et
en certain nombre de changements ont été
opérés puisque la constitution actuelle
était celle qui avait été approuvé en
plein milieu de la dictature de pinochet
c'était en 1981 et équipe en quelque
sorte contraignez les pouvoirs
démocratiques les sources entre nombre
des plans par exemple jusqu'en 2005 une
réforme et
les sénateurs avaient désigné par les
forces armées ou le président même élu
démocratiquement avec les plus rétifs
délimité pour changer par exemple et les
commandants en chef des différences
entre composantes des forces armées et
bien tout ça a été et ce suite à
différentes réformes la réforme de la
coupe de 180 ont été les nombreuses 25
bref on construit maintenant ce que les
quelque chose ce mouvement qui s'est
tenue hier demandé c'est de
véritablement construire un nouveau
cadre institutionnel et permettant de
donner plus et droit et encore une fois
à générer des modalités plus les
emportant de participation citoyenne
dans un pays où effectivement ces
citoyens n'a pas été très importants de
ces dernières années il ya eu et il ya
surtout beaucoup de satisfaction qui
fait des inégalités très marqué qui
caractérise le chili je suis arrêté
considéré pendant longtemps comme un
modèle de croissance économique
dynamique et s'arrête ça cesse a jamais
été un modèle mais c'était quand même un
pays dynamique mais la suite avec des
grands libéralisation de l'économie
certains des reignaux libéral or il
s'agit aujourd'hui
bedimo sans doute de donner plus
d'éléments de démocratie sociale et
politique
il faut dire que et tous ses processus
qui devrait déboucher sur l'élection des
constituants ou des députés pouvant
modifier la constitution des
représentants qui vont modifier la
position en avril prochain est né qui
n'était pas la panacée salut ça va
permettre plus disons dernier avocat
jallet mais après et évidemment ça
répondra et des mouvements sociaux et
politiques des choix des citoyens est
appelé avec 2021 alors un nouveau tête
une nouvelle constitution est ce que ça
va permettre de calmer un petit peu la
contestation actuelle
tu as bien évidemment disons ce
mouvement de contestation qui en fait
c'est arrêté seulement du fait de la
pandémie parce qu'il est était dynamique
tu les entends ce jusqu'au début de
cette année et 2020 et est en quelque
sorte canalisée par cette élection de
l'art de la nouvelle constitution cette
définition de la nouvelle constitution
donc je pense que je sais pas si calme
et en tout cas avant canaliser et nous
avons devant nous maintenant six mois et
des campagnes électorales pour ainsi
dire et qui devront déboucher sur
l'élection en avril prochain et
desserrer présentant à l'assemblée
constituante
donc oui on peut dire que ça devrait en
principe
sinon calme et encore une fois canaliser
donner un débouché politique finalement
même si il n'est pas improbable que des
manifestations et des mouvements de rue
et persistent comme de tenues bien
entendu de la crise de s'inviter à qui a
fortement affecté les chili comme toute
l'amérique du sud carlos canal merci
d'avoir été en direct avec nous sur arte
france rappelle que vous êtes professeur
à l'institut des hautes études
d'amérique latine de l'université paris
iii sorbonne nouvelle
mais aussi vice président de l'institut
des amériques merci à vous